par le passé
je n'ai vécu que pour ma mission
à présent
je vais me consacrer à ceux qui en ont
besoin
l'hôpital de chirurgie esthétique Médusa
enlève des gens sur lesquels ils mènent
des expériences nous vous avons attribué
une nouvelle identité vous allez
infiltrer Médusa et mener votre enquête
dites-moi pourquoi êtes-vous un filtrer
en Corée du Sud
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'évolution
humaine c'est le cadeau que Dieu vous
fait
d'où venez-vous
et qui vous envoie
remets-moi immédiatement la puce je ne
peux pas te la donner
avant la prochaine bataille de demain
[Musique]
watching Tchin toi et moi nous sommes
des spécimens humains parfaits
nous avons la possibilité de créer un
monde